harris ist wirklich hallo mein name ist
herzlich willkommen wir heute zu einem
neuen video von mir denken alle
chatroulette und zwar chatroulette ja so
dass man einfach mit irgendeinem
stranger mit einem unbekannten der
irgendwo anders auf der welt ist einfach
ein videochat machen kann wir
beschäftigen uns heute allerdings nicht
mit chatroulette sondern mit regeln und
zwar dass baumängel so dass man einfach
auf die website gehen kann man kann dann
ist eingehen wie beispielsweise konkrete
und jeder der diesen in schierstein
gegeben hat wird dann in einen raum
geschmissen und kann miteinander quasi
skypen in einer gewissen form und ich
habe euch bei twitter instagram und
snapshot gesagt er soll das ganze mal
machen und ich würde sagen jetzt machen
wir das comic look hallo hey was geht
was machst du so nix nix ne schöne story
gesehen was noch so ach ich doch gerade
das hast du gut auf youtube ich weiß
nicht ich weiß nicht was du gesagt hast
dich nicht mich maßlos besser lieblings
youtube als du denkst du was machst du
heute noch so entspannten sonntag
einfach schlafen schlafen okay du hast
das war's paar annett er war nett an
dieser konkretisierung gekommen ja die
auch erzeuge die fabrik soll dieser
kontrakt ist es doch alles irgendwie weg
bringt hallo bitte mich alter greifen
richten wir waren die anekdote als er
hört man gar nicht gekämpft hier aber
mir geht es blendend und euch schön was
ist 13 bis 9
schon die ganze zeit die ich mich schon
die ganze zeit was ich habe ich suche
ich auch schon mein leben lang habt ein
snap gesehen habe gesehen dass du also
nicht ein bisschen er auch um michael
biegler kann also hast du hast gar nicht
gesehen das gedacht du gehst jetzt mal
hier rein und sucht mich krass alter du
hast mich gefunden ich komme habe ich
den pokal ab für dich 2000 jahre später
noch keinen pokal eine wasserflasche
habe ich auch alter letztlich vielleicht
ein foto machen ein foto
danke dir ist gerade nacht oder nein für
mich eine kamera nicht die kamera geht
ich scheiße meine kamera geht jetzt auch
mehr leute
es gibt vielleicht überlegt die ganz
natürlich was bestellen sondern ob ich
was kochen soll heute sonntag ich kann
gar nicht einkaufen gehen podium soll
ich mir das kochen oder soll ich was
bestellen ich kann noch was bestellen
was gibt es für euch zu essen burritos
nein na ja wo regional kameras neu
isenburg das ist in der nähe von
frankfurt ich komme aus köln dass ich
komme ich aus köln nicht aus wieder
fällt aber ich wurde können das weiß ich
was weißt du sogar bis zum stalker denn
die hengste total er journalismus hat
mir leid bin übels anhänger hey hallo
na warst du ich höre ich ja dann eine
kamera qualität ist sowie die farbe von
meinem t-shirt
ich bin luca kein gold aber kann sich
auch gott nennen wie geht es dir so
jeden sehr gut
krass obwohl gerade mit mir redest hast
du die kamera an deinem bruder wo sie
[Musik]
kaputt nehmen wir ein fehler die kamera
kaputt ich wer ich bin sagt die domain
gott ich heiß luca da kann ich ja schon
wieder gehen
warte sagt sogar warten nicht so da also
okay ich dachte gar nicht habe ich etwas
kaputt gemacht du hast gehst so ein
geburtstag gefeiert führen die hessen
geworden 50 was machst du heute noch so
spielzeug twitter immer in der schule
schön aufpassen weil sonst endest du wie
babys beauty palace dass das sehe ich
genauso hallo
jeder sagt oh mein gott wie so kann man
nicht sagen hey luca ist das wirklich
natürlich will ich dahin auch schon so
hey bist du echt sexy jetzt der mir geht
es eigentlich ganz gut wir waren nur
gestern bisschen lang wach und ich habe
wenig gekämpft und jetzt bin ich ein
bisschen fertig und ich weiß nicht ich
habe gerade mit einem anderen edel
geredet und bei der werden gleich fotos
gemacht und ich habe hunger und ich will
jetzt auch gerne machen aber die ganzen
supermärkte haben jetzt deswegen weiß
ich nicht was ich jetzt machen soll
danke für die hilfreichen rat also ich
hab mir pizza bestellt hat das schön
welche pizza orientalisch e gitarre e
gitarre vier bio also irgendwie müssen
muss dass er
dazu kommen ach du studierst bio auf
lehramt oder bachelor also ok kostet
viel zu wenig wertschätzung so 105 fast
ohne sehkraft war ich nah dran hast du
das machst du wenn du das sorry dass ich
so aussehen ich habe hier irgend so ein
altes wetter an ich habe eine
jogginghose an
also sorry mir geht es blendend super
erklärt vierte klasse vierte klasse wäre
krass aber so achtbar 70
was möchte später werden wenn du groß
bist ich werde nächstes gern den
diensten cool freut mich hey hey hey was
geht ich bin so dass beide gerade weil
es hat ja ich bade gerade ich es gerade
in der badewanne derweil heftig meine
raw datei von dem video gerade also ich
finde das halt gerade und die raw datei
geht einfach seit 35 minuten unterhalt
nicht die ganze zeit mit leuten ich will
gar nicht auf wenn ich mal mega viel
spaß eigentlich verfügt was gepostet von
einer halben stunde habe ich mich schon
mit ein paar engländer unterhalte und
auf einmal im penis gezeigt es war halt
nicht so neu ist der himmel ist gehört
und machst du genau das wollte ich sagen
war zu wenig
alleiniger stoppen das geht los im
halbjahr um bronze
der tiger wie auch neugierig sie das
[Gelächter]
wie gefällt sowie rudi was gilt ist
seine hand nicht auch nicht ja klar
natürlich kann ich auch ein foto mit ihm
machen als video wirklich eintrifft was
ausmacht weil dann könnte ich ja auch
mal verschicken weil ich kein fan
treffen und so kommen weil ich in der
schweiz um runde
heikler logisch dann esse ich es nicht
ganz ganz lieber in der region als
erster auf instagram ihr heft laser luca
ok krass alle der folge nicht okay ich
würde mich erstmal verpissen dann wird
dein leben auch endlich mal wieder schön
hier
das was jetzt hier auch von mir meine
damen und herren ich wollte einfach mal
ein bisschen mit euch über umwege reden
und ja deswegen habe ich heute getan
wenn euch dieses format gefällt und ich
das vielleicht wöchentlich immer am
sonntag hochladen soll damit sonntag
segeltag anlass waren fetten daumen hoch
unter diesem video da und bei 40.000
daumen hoch das ist schon eine gewaltige
zahl da weiß ich dass er ist unbedingt
sehen wollt und schreib doch mal nägel
in die kommentare
weil dann ist komplett das wird zu
wissen und dann ist er tötet video
vorbei das was ihr vom video das was
jetzt hier vom video hier können jetzt
hier mal den kanal abonnieren oder hier
unten meinen job ausschenken ihr findet
ihr zwei andere videos und wenn ich
schon abonnent sein könnt ihr auf die
glocken klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]